it was like calm like a ghost I saw its
eyes shining white eyes and it does down
underground
the strange things going on all over the
city people behind this are not like you
and me
there's a hidden society it goes back
centuries yesterday wizard entered New
York with a case
a case full of magical creatures and
unfortunately some have escaped tini
you brought men home that's mr.
Scamander he's lost something I'm going
to help him find we're gonna recapture
my creatures before they get fed they're
currently in alien terrain surrounded by
millions of the most vicious creatures
on the planet humans
magical beasts i'll terrorize or no
matches no matches are afraid they
attack contain this little mean war it's
on look why would I have to wear
something like this because your skull
is a cept ought of breakage under
immense force
don't panic there's absolutely nothing
to worry about
I want to be a wizard
what makes Albus Dumbledore so fond of
you mr. Scamander first trip to America
yes